So geht wieder
Da ist es hart oder was ich sollte das bild schicken
Gut
Computer spiele preis
Vielleicht kriegen wir vielleicht kriegen wir das bild noch besser hin
Vielleicht kriegen wir das bild im fullscreen noch besser hin ohne ohne einblendung irgendwie
Okay, jetzt blendet sich nicht mehr aus
Das ist aber der beste moment gewesen dass der stream stehen bleibt
Speichern noch mal
Ich hoffe das stream geht jetzt wieder
Ich meine mein dsl modem nicht mal die es ein mein kabel modem hat die singt
einfach so
Ohne schon wieder kaputt
oder
schon wieder kaputt
aber aber der stream ist rap
na
zwischen auf steam das ist schon aller ehren wert und ich würde sagen wir gucken uns mal an was die jungs zu sagen haben
Okay
Nee das ist ein
Studio aus leute ganz ehrlich
Soll ich euch meine ehrliche meinung sagen mich juckt der deutsche computer spiele preis überhaupt nicht
Ich glaube wir hören jetzt aufzugucken oder wollt ihr weitergucken mich juckt überhaupt gar nicht das ist mir absolut scheißegal
Bitte nicht schauen was genau macht jetzt schöneberger bei der computer spielpreis man weiß es nicht so genau
Die war letztes jahr auch da das ist wahrscheinlich auch das
was sie qualifiziert
Wahrscheinlich dass sie auch vorhanden ist ja das gibt ja bestimmt genug die das moderieren können warum ist denn jetzt eigentlich alles hier mega im
arsch
Da fuck warum
Warum geht man peter bord nicht weil eben ein internet kaputt war
mcfly hat abonniert keine sounds gekommen
Wtf leute ich höre keine ich höre keine sap sounds ja dankeschön für den zap
Okay, wir waren es wieder ausgefordert
ist die schalte
Okay, wenn man das trägt 17
wir machen uns einfach im traum auf
a exit nicht
Geht auch nicht wo ist das problem
das ist lokales
da fuck
Okay, reboot reboot easy
Neue ip das ist lokal bei mir
Es ist lokal da gibt es nichts mit rebooten
Also da wo wir gerade beim thema sind ihr habt gesagt ich soll mir das video hier angucken
Da gucken wir uns jetzt mal das video an und flamen ein bisschen mit
Ich habe ja auch schon ein paar videos zu dem thema gemacht
Und mein fazit war ja auch immer eher eher schlecht
Aber ich muss erst wieder ein peter bord zum laufen bekommen sonst
Sag mal kann es sein dass ich nicht connecten kann zu zu fonds google api was auch immer
Kann es sein dass ich nirgends wohin connecten kann gerade ist es gerade down vodafone punkt de
What the hell warum ist das warum ist das warum kann ich mich meiner fremden hin korrekten
Und geht ja auch nicht. Oh leute
Der dns ich habe google dns drinne ich habe ich habe die google dns drinne oder
Ich komme nicht mehr zum google dns aber wisst ihr was das gute ist leute
Der stream läuft aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen gründen noch
Oh 1111 geht sie schwer stellen um eigentlich will ich jetzt nichts anfassen er
Eigentlich will ich jetzt nichts anfassen ich hoffe es geht einfach alles ich hoffe es geht einfach alles
wir können halt wir können halt keine
Wir können keine videos aufmachen und so
Aber das geht ja bestimmt gleich wir gucken jetzt einfach das video hier an das geht auch das läuft auch weiter alles gut alles top wunderbar
Und die f verarscht mich nicht jetzt nichts f der chat alter der chat
Wisst ihr was wir machen wenn ihr mich weiter debate leute
Hier wird nicht debate
Hier wird nicht debate leute
So gucken wir uns das video an
war
was war das video an der hat passt ja gerade passt exzellent
passt ja gerade
zum thema
Wir gucken wir beobachten mal ob der google dns wieder zu funktionieren glaubt
Ist eigentlich meine mikrofon settings richtig das ist gerade richtig das ist wirklich so so ist voll in der schwebe
Ich ich ich gucke jetzt alle zwei sekunden darüber ob das stream noch läuft weil unity media so am abscheißen ist wo davon
Ich habe halt die bedenken wenn ich da jetzt
Neuen dns ich meine das ist windows ja ich meine das ist das ist windows
Und ich habe angst dass das netzwerk interface reconnected wenn ich den dns ändere
leute windows profis
reconnected der das netzwerk interface neu wenn ich den dns ändere
Ich weiß noch nicht mal wie man überhaupt das komische menü reinkommt
Einfach machen
Was ist überhaupt das richtige interface hat er da glaube ich
Also probieren wir mal
Ja ja gut das ist mein eigener dns der geht aber direkt auf google
Bam bam
So
Und google geht wieder was
Kirby gourmet race ist nicht am start
Was nintendo
Out anzeige ist raus
ip league
Oh fuck
Oh fuck leute
Jetzt ist vorbei
Moment wo war's alp league
Scheiße
RIP
Alp league
OMFG
Der Dase ist raus
Ok wir gucken uns mal das Video an weil das passt ja richtig gut zum thema
Ich drehe hier bald ab
Ja wir auch gerade
Schon wieder neues update für color view divo um 20 gigabyte
Dabei wollte ich eigentlich nur eine mögliche Runde zucken
Tja, bis das Update geladen ist, da ist es morgen früh.
Was soll der Scheiß?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Warum die Updates haben, die größer sind als die meisten Spiele?
Hallo und willkommen zu einem neuen Scheiß der Woche.
Doch, ich glaube, von ihm habe ich schon mal was gesehen.
Im zweiten Video meines neuen Aufreger-Formates.
Hier präsentiere ich euch heute mal wieder große und auch mal kleine Aufreger der letzten Zeit.
Und wenn ich eins kann, dann ist es mich aufzuregen.
Denn sobald mich irgendwas nervt, da steigt mein Blutdruck schneller an,
als die Temperatur eines Intel Core i9-9100KS.
Und eine Sache, die macht meinem Hausarzt so langsam große Sorgen.
Warum meinem Hausarzt jetzt?
Ja, weil das ein Thema ist, das nicht erst seit ein paar Tagen...
Ja, es hat jemand gemeint, er schreit nicht.
Aber man kann sich auch aufregen, ohne zu schreien.
...und existiert.
Nein, es existiert schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Nämlich das Thema Internet in Deutschland.
Und wie ihr an meiner blassen, fahlen und erschrumpeligen Haut sehen könnt,
bin ich ja jetzt nicht unbedingt mehr ein Teenie.
Und habe die Internetzeit von Anfang an bis heute miterlebt.
Ja, Leute, wer hatte noch einen Modem bei sich daheim?
Haben wir noch genug Boomer im Chat, die das miterlebt haben?
Also ich hatte sowohl einen 336 als auch einen 56K.
Nur Boomer im Chat, ich sehe es, ich sehe es, Leute.
56K Boomer.
Ja, ich hatte sogar einen Modem, hat schon mal erzählt, mit Fax.
Mit eingebausten...
Mit einem 4MB Flash-Speicher, wo man Faxe drauf speichern konnte, auf dem Modem.
Und sogar Anrufe mit 4MB Flash.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Mit 4MB Flash, das ist heute mehr als auf meinem Microcontroller drauf ist.
Äh, weniger als auf meinem Microcontroller drauf ist.
Jawohl, ich gehöre zu denjenigen, die noch mit einem herkömmlichen, quäkenden Modem das Internet erkundet haben.
Ich gehöre noch zu der AOL-Ära, mit diesem wunderbaren Satz hier.
Sie haben Post.
Ich war damals happy, als wir ISDN bekommen haben und ich mit Leitungsverdopplung...
ISDN war auch so ein Ding, wo sie meiner Ansicht nach komplett die Zeit verschlafen haben.
ISDN war so... ISDN war komplett telefonoptimiert.
Da war Internet ein zweiter Gedanke dabei.
ISDN war Telefon, Fax und halt so Oldschool-Telekommunikations-Server.
Das Internet hat da überhaupt keiner gedacht.
Wahnwitzige 14 KB die Sekunde downloaden konnte.
Zu hohen Kosten wohlgemerkt.
Bei AOL kommen erstmal so allgemein Minutenabrechnungen zu.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau, aber ich meine es waren so 5 bis 7 DM pro Stunde.
Was?
Nee.
Achso, okay.
Das war vielleicht dann auch vor meiner Zeit.
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber so teuer war es nicht, als ich angefangen habe mit dem 56K-Modem.
Ähm.
Du musstest aber zweimal bezahlen.
Du musstest deinen Internet-Provider bezahlen.
Und du musstest die Telefonkosten bezahlen.
Und Telefongebühren.
Ja, genau.
Internet war also eine sehr teure Angelegenheit.
Und daher nur was für blasse und picklige Computerfreaks, wie ich einer war.
Und damals waren gefühlt andere Länder schon deutlich weiter als wir.
Und irgendwann kam der Zeitpunkt, an dem fast alle Welt auf Glas gesetzt hat.
Ist das nicht schön?
Ist das nicht wunderschön?
Ja, Kanalbündelung.
Kanalbündelung war tatsächlich nice.
Wo man Sonntagsinterview...
Wo man Sonntags kostenlos, in Anführungsstrichen, ins Internet konnte.
Da hat man Kanalbündelung angeschlossen.
Und konnte damals dann mit...
Was war eigentlich die Endkanalbündelung?
12K?
16K?
16K, oder?
Was war, was war, was?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau.
14,5K?
14,4K?
Es war auf jeden Fall nicht schnell.
Ähm.
Und es war aber richtig cool, weil man damals Napster benutzen konnte.
Und man konnte damals mit all seinen Kanalbündelungen Sachen auf Napster downloaden und gleichzeitig abspielen.
Also, so ein Art Streaming.
Leider nein, denn ein kleines, aber sehr starkes Industrieland mit einem leicht übergewichtigen Bundeskanzler schwamm gegen den Strom und setzte voll und ganz auf Kupfer.
Ja, das glänzt natürlich auch so schön rot-golden.
Ja, unter dieser Entscheidung hat Deutschland bis heute zu knabbern.
Das stimmt.
Und nun kommen wir zu dem Punkt, auf dem ich eigentlich mit diesem Video hinaus...
Das stimmt. Und lustigerweise in den Bereichen, wo man Glas verlegt hat, haben wir es so gemacht, dass es jetzt nicht mehr verwendbar ist.
Das Internet in Deutschland ist absoluter Müll.
Ja, sicher. Es gibt viele Länder, denen es internetmäßig noch deutlich schlechter geht.
Ja, Uganda.
Das will ich überhaupt nicht verheimlichen.
Turkmenistan ist zum Beispiel so weit unten in den weltweiten Downloadlisten, dass das Land einem wirklich leid tun kann.
Mit nicht mal zwei MB Download im Schnitt.
Ja.
Turkmenistan ist die viertgrößte Wirtschaftsnation der Welt.
Noch.
Und im weltweiten Vergleich der Downloadgeschwindigkeiten befinden wir uns hinter Ländern wie zum Beispiel Slowenien, der Slowakei, wie Litauen, Ungarn oder wie Estland.
Kein Hate.
Alles durchaus schöne Länder.
Aber so richtige Industrienationen sind das ja jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Was ist los mit dem deutschen Internet?
Und laut der aktuellsten Statistik von cable.co.uk, wo Deutschland 2019 quasi kein Wachstum bei der Internetgeschwindigkeit...
Ja, weil wir es ja auch seit Jahren verkacken.
... mehr als 2018.
Zwei Prozent.
Wir sind auf Platz 27.
Weil wir es auch seit Jahren verkacken.
Weil wir auch so eine komische Ausbauförderungsregel wieder haben, wo so nach dem Motto hier, wenn hier mal modernisiert wurde...
Auch das PPGaBoard ist aufgegangen.
Wenn das mal modernisiert wurde, dann darf jetzt seit den nächsten zehn Jahren wieder nichts gemacht werden.
Dann buddeln Vodafone, Telekom, wer auch immer, alles parallel die Straße auf.
Es ist bei uns voll planlos.
Damit noch schlechter als es ist.
Damit noch schlechter als 2018.
In der ganzen Liste hinter uns finde ich nur zwei weitere westliche Industrienationen, die vergleichbar sind.
Und zwar Österreich und Großbritannien.
Okay, die Briten wollen eh nirgendwo zugehören und überall nur Extrawürste.
Die wollen ja eh mit niemand anderem Internetverkehr, außer mit sich selbst.
Frame-Drops.
Durchaus möglich.
Der ganze Stream ist gerade dank Vodafone verreckt.
Ja, anscheinend haben wir gerade ein bisschen Frame-Drops wieder.
Aber ich bin ja froh, dass der Stream überhaupt läuft.
Vodashit, genau.
Vodashit.
Daher Britannien, egal.
Aktuelle Statistik von kelvin.co.uk besagt 2019 ein Durchschnittsdownload von 25 MBit in Deutschland.
Hier muss ich jetzt aber kurz noch erwähnen, dass die Daten von zum Beispiel dieser Seite und zum Beispiel von Speedtest,
die ja auch reale Daten nutzen und keine vertraglichen, die Daten enorm differieren.
Das Beste ist immer noch der Breitbandatlas.
Und selbst wenn der in den Default-Settings geschönt ist und gehen wir mal von außen,
das ist die geschönte Variante und die ist immer noch schlecht.
Das sagt alles.
Im Schnitt zum Beispiel 94,73 MBit, ist aber sogar nur auf Platz 31 zu finden.
Meine Erfahrungen sind den Werten von cable.co.uk aber eher zu trauen.
Falls jemand eine Idee hat, wie diese enorme Differenz zustande kommt, schreibt das bitte unbedingt in die Kommentare, denn ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Und wer liegt an der Spitze der Listen?
Nahezu unabhängig welche Liste?
Südkorea?
Südkorea ist glaube ich auch ziemlich gut, oder?
Die Schweiz, die Schweiz ist doch auch gut.
Ja, da ist die Schweiz.
Hatte Südkorea nicht auch ordentlich Internetanschluss?
Scheint nicht so gut zu sein hier dabei.
Aber die Schweiz ist ziemlich gut.
Ich meine, die müssen ja auch nur einen großen Funkmast auf den Bash stellen und dann haben alle Internet.
71 MBit dahinter.
Das sind absolute Traumzahlen für Deutschland.
Ja, und in Europa ist es wohl das Sympathische.
Das ist das größte Land des ganzen Kontinents.
Die Schweden haben in Sachen Internet ihre blonden Haare weit vorne.
Mit 55 MBit.
Das wäre für Deutschland ja alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Wenn es bei uns auch zumindest irgendwie voran ginge.
Aber genau das passiert hier aktuell nicht.
Ja, das kriegen wir nicht hin.
Da hat er recht.
Die Schweiz zum Beispiel hat gegenüber 2018 um 30% zugelegt.
Die Schweiz, ebenfalls so ein Land, das ja immer nur sagt, nein, nein, damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben.
Wir bleiben für uns alleine.
Nein, keine EU.
Und trotz diverser Pakete der Bundesregierung sehe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Besserung.
Trotz, dass die Bundesregierung viele Milliarden an Geldern bereitstellt, geht es einfach nicht voran.
Denn diese Gelder werden einfach nicht von den Kommunen abgerufen.
Bürokratiewahnsinn ist nämlich das Problem.
Ja, und dann kommen natürlich auch noch die ganzen Anbieter dazu.
Ob Telekom, ob Vodafone.
Ausbau findet nur in lukrativen Gegenden statt.
Und solange die Regierung die Anbieter nicht...
Da musst du halt...
Du musst die Anbieter dazu zwingen im Endeffekt.
Oder du gehst gleich so weit und sagst, ja...
Scheiß auf die Anbieter.
Wir kümmern uns da von oberer Stelle drum.
Ob das jetzt besser wäre?
Schwierig, aber...
Wie, Anbieter machen das doch nicht freiwillig.
Warum sollte ein Anbieter einen Bauernhof anschließen, der irgendwo am Arsch der Welt liegt zum Beispiel?
Wozu?
Was haben die davon?
Nichts.
Kostet Geld ohne Ende.
Bringt nichts.
... dazu bringt, auch in nicht lukrativen Gebieten auszubauen, bleibt es natürlich so, wie es aktuell ist.
Nur in extremen Ballungsräumen gibt es Glasfaser.
Woanders wird weiterhin auf veraltete Kupferleitungen und mit Glück auch noch VDSL gesetzt,
statt die Glasfaser komplett bis ins Haus zu legen.
Tja.
Und am geilsten sind ja so einige Fälle, in denen Kommunen das selbst in die Hand genommen haben
und Glasfaser dann halt selbst gelegt haben,
nur damit einige Zeit später die Telekom die Gräben wieder aufbuddelt
und dann noch eine Glasfaserstrampe reinlegt.
Ja, das hast du schon öfters mal gehabt.
Richtig verstanden.
Zweimal Glasfaser.
Aber man...
Das wäre ja nicht schlimm.
Das wäre überhaupt nicht schlimm, wenn da zweimal Glasfaser liegt.
Sofern das halt keinen negativen Einfluss hat.
... nicht nur auf die Telekom schieben.
Das ist nun mal ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen, das kostendeckend arbeiten muss.
Das Ganze ist nun mal ein Regierungsproblem.
Und sorry, wenn ich das jetzt mal so direkt sage.
Das stimmt.
Die meisten älteren Damen und Herren haben offensichtlich nun mal keinen großen Bezug zum Internet.
Kein Plan.
Man hat ja bei denen immer das Gefühl, dass nur das vorangebracht wird, was auch persönlich interessant ist.
Was auch persönlich interessiert und wichtig scheint.
Es wird überhaupt nichts vorangebracht, was mich persönlich...
Also gar nichts vielleicht nicht, aber sehr wenig, was mich persönlich interessiert.
... aber es fühlt sich für mich auf jeden Fall immer so an.
Und manchmal glaube ich sogar, dass die alten Damen und Herren überhaupt nicht verstehen,
wie wichtig schnelles Internet für die Wirtschaft in Deutschland ist.
Man kann sich doch nicht ewig auf die Autometallbauindustrie verlassen,
wie er schon seit gefühlt hunderten von Jahren.
Denn es ist so,
wir haben den digitalen Anschluss komplett verpasst.
Wo sind denn die großen IT-Konzerne in Deutschland?
Wir haben witzigerweise, ich habe letztens einen Artikel drüber gelesen,
das ist ein tolles Standbild.
Ich habe letztens einen coolen Artikel drüber gelesen,
dass wir in Deutschland gerade einen, nennen wir es mal,
mini bis mittleren Aufschwung beziehungsweise Neugründung und Erfolg von Technikunternehmen haben.
Und das Fazit von diesem Artikel hat mich dann aber gleich wieder an die Realität erinnert,
dass das ja Deutschland ist.
Und zwar haben die geschrieben, dass es relativ viele neue Technikunternehmen gibt
und da auch relativ viele im Vergleich zu früher erfolgreich sind.
Und warum sind die erfolgreich?
Ja SAP haben wir, ich glaube, haben wir nicht.
Wir hatten mal Crytek, was Games angeht.
Zumindest die sind zu dem Fazit gekommen,
die ganzen etwas kleineren und mittleren IT-Läden,
die jetzt gegründet werden, die es schon eine Weile gibt,
denen es jetzt gut geht, die halt gut was zu tun haben,
das liegt daran, nicht weil die neue innovative Sachen machen,
sondern weil die ganz Großen in Deutschland gerade anfangen festzustellen,
dass sie IT-mäßig und Infrastruktur-mäßig komplett hinten dran sind.
Das heißt, die kleineren Unternehmen sind nur da,
die kleineren Unternehmen sind nur erfolgreich,
weil sie den Großen quasi Sachen von vorgestern verkaufen können,
weil die so weit hinten dran sind.
So ist das halt hier.
Die großen Online-Shops in Deutschland, wo die wirklich große...
Ja, die großen Online-Shops, da muss ich jetzt auch noch kurz was sagen.
Die großen Online-Shops, also das haben wir auch so extrem krass verschissen.
Es leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein, was in Bochum gibt es auch.
Startup-Gründerszene, ja.
Genau, was ich sagen wollte, das haben wir auch so verschissen.
Und zwar, wir hatten ja früher, was gab es denn da?
Otto, Quelle, Neckermann und sowas.
Und ich habe gelesen, dass entweder war es Quelle oder war es Otto,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die halt noch Original-Quelle Otto waren,
dass die bis zum Schluss den meisten Umsatz mit Katalog-Deals gewonnen haben.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her.
Fünf Jahre oder so.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und die haben so heftig den Anschluss verpasst.
Die waren ja schon in Deutschland, die waren schon lange da.
Die waren etabliert.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Amazon hier so easy Fuß gefasst hätte
und quasi im Alleingang die Sache aufgerollt hätte,
wenn die frühzeitig...
da mitgemacht hätten und das Ganze erkannt hätten.
Aber das haben die so verkackt.
Das war so, oh was, Internet, lull, wir machen Katalog.
Ja, Fail, ne?
Startups.
Das mag sein, ich weiß nicht, ob es Otto oder Quelle war,
als die noch Original waren.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass das jetzt anders ist.
Wie es sie zum Beispiel in den USA zuhauf gibt.
Wobei natürlich auch die USA jetzt nicht das allerschnellste Internet haben.
So ehrlich muss ich mal sein.
Ob Clouds, ob VPNs, ob Homeoffice.
Datenverkehr zwischen Firmen, Schulen.
Und ja, auch Uploads von YouTubern und Twitchern,
die gehören zur Industrie in Deutschland.
Auch wenn das die Regierung vielleicht ein bisschen anders sieht.
Das alles funktioniert in Deutschland mehr schlecht als recht.
Und ja, den Upload, den vergessen viele übrigens total.
Denn der ist besonders für die Industrie oft viel, viel wichtiger als der Download.
Und dass ein hoher Download wenig bringt,
wenn der Upload auf niedrigem Niveau ist,
das muss sich hoffentlich jetzt niemand erklären.
Denn dazu bedarf es definitiv keines Mathematikprofessors.
In meiner alten Firma musste ich zum Beispiel sehr viel das Internet nutzen.
Ich glaube, das ist vielen gar nicht so klar.
Also, bei den normalen Downloads ist es natürlich wichtig,
dass man eine Mindestanzahl an Upload hat.
Sonst kriegt man gar nicht den vollen Download.
Aber dafür ist potenziell genug da.
Aber das Verhältnis ist total beknackt.
Der Cooper1338 schreibt im Chat gerade was langes.
Das muss ich gerade mal kurz vorlesen.
Was geht es da?
Ein Kumpel von mir hat ein Praktikum bei BMW gemacht.
Die wollen sich dann für ein Projekt eine digitale Lösung einkaufen.
Aha.
Da kam dann unter anderem auch SAP zu einer Präsentation.
Die haben ungelogen richtigen Müll gelabert.
Gut, das sind halt Vertriebs- und BWL-Blender-Leute.
Das ist denen ihr Job, quasi zu überzeugen.
Der schreibt, die haben ungelogen richtigen Müll gelabert.
Und die Lösung war super toll und bot kaum Vorteile.
Total statisch, kaum Raum für Individualisierung.
Und dann hatten die noch ein Start-up aus Frankreich,
die eine super geniale, innovative Lösung präsentiert hat.
Ja, da wird sich aber der Chef denken,
das Ding aus Frankreich kann morgen weg sein.
Keine Sau, Kenz gibt keine zusätzlichen Module.
Wir kaufen SAP.
Und ihr habt garantiert SAP gekauft.
Zurzeit läuft Computerspiele preisfällig.
Ja, wir haben sogar am Anfang mal reingeguckt.
Hier, guck.
Wir haben sogar ein schönes Bild gemacht.
Das sieht echt zum Fürchten aus, Alter.
Patrick, wer wollte das mit dem Emote machen?
Ich schick's dir nachher im Discord.
Armstreben.
Kaum möglich.
Trotz offizieller 300 MBit-Leitung für die ganze Firma.
Aber per Kabel.
Vor kurzem habe ich mit meinem Steuerbeamten
gesprochen.
Der hofft endlich auf Glasfaser-Freischaltung
und meinte sogar, dass das ganze geschäftsschädigend wäre,
dass sie mit den Idealen überhaupt keinen ordentlichen
Datenaustausch durchführen können.
Weiteres Beispiel bei uns im Ort.
Das ist nicht nur geschäftsschädigend,
das ist komplett geschäftshemmend,
wenn du keinen Internetanschluss heutzutage hast.
Schiebt langsam regelrecht aus.
Immer mal Firmen machen hier dicht oder wandern ab.
Die alten Gebäude finden dann keine neuen Besitzer.
Warum?
Das Internet natürlich.
Ich würde mich doch nicht so einem Ort niederlassen,
der hier maximal sechs,
maximal sechs MBit im Download liefert.
Und das ist natürlich nicht nur hier so.
Welche Möglichkeiten Startups,
größere Firmen usw.
mit schnellem Internet hätten,
das ist überhaupt nicht auszumalen.
Ja klar, auch privat ist langsames Internet
mittlerweile natürlich ein Graus.
Bestes Beispiel natürlich aus meinem Intro.
Neue Patch für ein Spiel von mehreren Gigabyte,
damit ist der gemütliche Zockeramt bei mir
in der Regel immer Geschichte.
Oder YouTube?
Mal ebenso schnell ein größeres Video hochladen,
das ist überhaupt nicht möglich.
Das dauerte bei mir bis vor kurzem
zwei bis drei Stunden.
Monty, warum bist du nicht auf Twitch?
Na, ratet mal, weil mein Upload scheiße ist.
Ich könnte mich noch stundenlang
über den ganzen Mist aufregen,
aber ich will natürlich auch irgendwann
jetzt mal zum Ende kommen.
Wobei, nein, Moment,
ein Aufreger, den muss...
Frametrops.
Es kann sein, dass es Frametrops gibt.
Vodafone bzw. Unity Media
ist gerade wieder übelst am Abscheißen.
Geht eigentlich der Google-DNS mittlerweile wieder?
Ah, excellent, okay.
Geht wieder.
Geht wieder, ist wieder ganz...
Zur Telekom natürlich.
Ich musste mich ja jahrelang mit einer offiziellen
16-Mbit-Leitung und einem Mbit-Upload bemühen,
bei der übrigens...
PC Lustig schreibt einmal ehrlich, 80% der meisten
Privatbenutzer brauchen doch kaum Geschwindigkeit.
Doch, brauchen sie.
Also definiere mal was ist kaum.
In der heutigen Zeit, wo immer mehr Sachen...
Warte mal.
So.
In der heutigen Zeit, wo immer mehr Sachen
online gemacht werden, die meisten Leute,
wenn die am Rechner sitzen, am Tablet, am sonst wo,
das sind 90% Browser-Anwendungen.
Die Leute machen 90% Browser-Zeug.
Die Leute speichern immer mehr Sachen online.
Die Leute bearbeiten immer mehr Sachen online.
Es macht offline, so richtig offline
machen die Leute ja kaum noch was.
Es werden Daten gesynct, es werden Videos gestreamt,
es wird Musik gestreamt.
Es sind mehrere Leute im Haushalt, die heutzutage,
und das ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich weit hergeholt,
dass jemand einen 4K-Film guckt,
vielleicht auch jemand anderes einen 4K-Film guckt,
ein anderer macht einen Steam-Download,
und einer macht Backup oder so.
Das ist ja nicht jetzt komplett utopisch,
was ich erzähle.
Das sind ganz normale Anwendungsszenarien,
die ganz normale 0815-Familien
mit Vater, Mutter, Kind haben.
Und da kommst du mit 6 MBit nicht aus.
Das reicht nicht.
Das ist schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig.
Da kommst du nicht mit hin.
Ich hab's ja mal in einem Video gesagt,
dass wenn eine Familie, Mutter, Vater, Kind,
vielleicht sogar Mutter, Vater, zwei Kinder,
da gibt's ja welche, die kriegen tatsächlich zwei Kinder noch,
ich kann's ja nicht verstehen, warum man überhaupt Kinder kriegt,
aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema,
aber Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder,
die brauchen eigentlich mindestens 50 MBit.
Dass das wirklich auch rund um die Uhr
halbwegs gut läuft, auch in Stoßzeiten.
Und das gibt's halt wenig.
Wir haben uns doch letztens auf den Breitbandausbau das Ganze angeguckt.
50 MBit kriegst du bei weitem nicht überall.
... 12 MBit ankamen.
Immer wieder fragte ich die Telekom,
wann ich denn mal immer mehr erhalte.
Und seit Jahren wurde mir immer wieder gesagt,
dass hier bei uns ja Ausbau...
Ja, das mit dem Stream-Abkanten.
Vodafone hat richtige Probleme gerade.
Ähm, seht ihr da?
Framedrops ohne Ende wieder.
Ach, Vodafone, meine Fresse.
So ein Scheißladen, Alter.
Ich kündige jetzt, ey.
Die Kündigung ist raus.
Da gab's doch diese komische Störung.
Alle Störungen, genau.
Bäm!
Leute, guckt euch das mal an hier.
Huihi, da geht's rauf.
Flop!
Äh, what the fuck?
Okay.
Ich stell mal kurz runter.
Mal gucken, ob das dann irgendwie was bringt.
Haben wir...
Was ist Leak?
Hier ist nix Leak, Leute.
Hier geht's voll kaputt an.
SCBA 42, 6 Monate.
Stream-Settings liegt, oh mein Gott.
Äh, Potato Church, man.
Das liegt nicht unbedingt an den ganzen Noobs im Internet.
Das liegt halt an unseren Providern, die es verkacken.
Und generell am Internet in Deutschland, wo wir gerade wieder beim Thema sind.
Ähm...
Wir gucken, das Video ist noch mal kurz fertig.
Ah, der Sub-Sound war kaputt. Hab ich was übersehen?
Ja, der Sub-Sound ist abgekackt mit Vodafone.
Äh, SCBA 42, huge Sub. Dankeschön. 6 Monate.
Ansonsten noch einen vergessen?
Ah, der Stream laggt wieder. Ich seh's in der Vorschau.
Und ich kann nichts dagegen machen.
Ich kann wirklich heute nix, gar nix.
Wir müssen auch bei dem Rumgespacke von Vodafone nicht davon ausgehen,
dass es irgendwie, äh, heute anders wird noch, ne?
Ich würde jetzt ja gern auf Twitter gehen und Vodafone flamen.
Die Sache ist bloß die,
die Leute im Twitter-Support,
die haben damit, die haben da überhaupt keinen Einfluss drauf.
Und letztendlich läuft es darauf raus,
dass man sich mit Technikern beschäftigen muss,
die auch nix dran ändern können.
Router raus und reingesteckt, SSIDs vom WLAN geändert.
So, ich hoffe, wir haben's jetzt, äh,
dass wir zumindest das eine Video jetzt fertig gucken können.
Er hat ja voll und ganz recht.
So, so, Ausbaugebiet.
Dann kam immerhin etwas Rettung in Form von meinem Hybridanschluss
mit 50 MBitDown und 10 MBitUpload.
Hybridanschluss, das ist auch so ne,
das ist auch so ne absolute Bullshit-Technologie, ey.
Ich mein, dass sie, dass sie, dass sie so gut, in Anführungsstrichen,
funktioniert, ist technisch nice gemacht, ja.
Ähm, aber dass man so ne Scheiße überhaupt braucht.
So, deutlich wichtiger, da meine Videos so halt keine 2-3 Stunden
mehr zum Upload brauchten.
Und ja, der Upload funktionierte durchaus stabil bei 10-11 MBit.
Stream ist mit so einer Hybridleitung
aufgrund der sehr wackeligen Verbindung
aber, äh, jetzt nicht in guter Qualität möglich.
Das nur mal zur Info.
Ja, beim Download, da saß er so,
da sah es aber leider sehr übel aus.
Kaum mehr als mit normalen DLS.
Für kurze Zeit vielleicht mal 30 MBit,
meist aber leider deutlich unter 20 MBit.
Ja, und dann hat unser Ort hier Glasfaser
einfach mal in die eigenen Hände genommen und ausgebaut.
Im Frühjahr 2020 sollte es bei mir dann auch soweit sein.
Na, da passte das Ganze jetzt nicht mit dem Kündigungstermin
der Telekom zusammen.
Da hat sich das jetzt so ein bisschen blöd überschnitten.
Ja, mein Telekom-Vertrag läuft jetzt leider noch ein ganzes Jahr weiter.
Naja, nach der Kündigung rief dann eine Dame an und fragte nach dem Grund.
Den ich ihr natürlich nannte.
Neuer Anbieter mit Glasfaser und eine katastrophal schlechte Hybridleitung.
Und ich machte einen ganz großen Fehler.
Ich sprach nämlich ein eventuelles Sonderkündigungsrecht an,
weil bei mir halt so wenig ankommt.
Ob es das gibt, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Jedenfalls, was passierte?
Nur wenige Stunden später habe ich fast 60 MBit per Hybrid gehabt.
Ich kündige und plötzlich geht es Telekom.
Wollt ihr mich eigentlich total verarschen?
Ja, und das Ende vom Lied.
Ich habe jetzt endlich meinen lang ersehnten Glasfaseranschluss.
Muss aber leider doppelt sein.
Eine Sache habe ich auch gemerkt,
dass du durchaus Vorteile hast, wenn du nervig bist.
Wie gesagt, ich habe damals auch bei Unity Media
einen Monat lang bin ich denen auf Twitter überall auf den Sack gegangen.
Und schon hatte ich wieder keinen Dual-Stack-Light,
sondern einen ordentlichen Anschluss.
Das ist Zufall mit dem Speed.
Ja, es wäre merkwürdig, würden sie das machen.
Aber zumindest bei Vodafone bzw. bei Unity Media hat das Meckern was gebracht.
Allerdings nicht speedmäßig, sondern halt, dass ich keinen Dual-Stack-Light mehr hatte.
Aber dafür bezahle ich jetzt doppelt.
Ist auch egal.
Ich bezahle jetzt gerade doppelt Power-Upload bei Unity Media.
Zweimal.
Ich kriege nur einmal Power-Upload, aber ich bezahle zweimal Power-Upload.
Aber das ist es irgendwie auch wert, dass ich dann endlich bald mal mit Twitch anfangen kann.
Aktuell sind es dann 400 MBit Down und 100 MBit Upload.
Ob das jetzt so ankommt, weiß ich noch nicht,
da ich den Anschluss bei Produktion dieses Videos hier leider noch nicht in Betrieb hatte.
Und ja, 400 MBit für Glasfaser, das ist wenig.
Aber mehr ginge auch.
Aber ich denke mir, wozu eigentlich?
Apropos mehr ginge.
Siehe Vodafone.
Noch so ein Anbieter, von dem man überhaupt nichts Gutes hört.
Man hört von keinem Anbieter.
Gibt es irgendeinen Anbieter, von dem man was Gutes hört,
was jetzt nicht gerade irgendein lokaler Anbieter ist?
Über Kabel.
Soweit ich weiß, bietet Vodafone übrigens kein normales Glasfaser an.
Und Kabelleitungen haben hier halt leider so ihre Tücken.
So natürlich auch bei Vodafone.
Die bieten ein Gigabit an.
Im Download.
Hauptsache, neue Kunden akquirieren.
Wie das technisch umsetzbar ist, das scheint Vodafone doch völlig egal zu sein.
Das geht ihnen auch am Arsch vorbei.
Das scheint wohl jetzt schon ziemlich am Limit zu sein.
Ein Gigabit kommt fast bei niemanden an.
Viele bekommen nicht mal die Hälfte der zugesagten Bandbreite.
Und abends bricht das Netz auch noch hoch.
Bis zu.
Super, ein Gigabit-Leitung von Vodafone.
Klasse gemacht.
Wer braucht sowas?
Und was soll der Scheiß?
Wenn ihr doch nicht genug Kapazitäten habt, dann verkauft doch sowas nicht.
Ich finde, sowas sollte echt verboten werden.
Und wo wir dann auch noch beim Thema der vertraglichen Geschwindigkeiten sind,
die ja wohl in Deutschland der größte Witz überhaupt sind.
Nur die wenigsten erhalten auch das, was sie überhaupt gebucht haben.
Ja.
Bis zu.
Ist jetzt bei der Telekom.
Okay, gebe ich zu.
Trotzdem fühle ich mich irgendwie verarscht.
Und laut dem letzten Bericht der Bundesnetzagentur bekommen nur 70 Prozent mindestens die Hälfte
der vereinbarten Übertragungsrate.
70 Prozent die Hälfte.
Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Lediglich 16,4 Prozent erhalten das Gebuchte oder gar mehr.
Das ist doch wohl ein Witz.
Wie ich diese Worte hasse.
Bis zu.
Bis zu, ja.
Das ist ja schon schlimm genug.
Noch dazu werden so natürlich auch viele Statistiken wunderschön gerechnet.
Wenn man halt die vertraglich vereinbarten Zahlen nimmt.
Ja.
Und unter den Twitter überkehrt, was wirklich ankommt.
Ist das denn so schwer?
Also im Statistiken faken und Sachen schön rechnen sind viel gut.
Guckt euch mal die Pünktlichkeitsstatistik der Bahn an.
Also krasser zusammenfaken kannst du nicht mehr.
Auf den Weg zu bringen, dass den Anbietern sowas verbietet, ist jetzt so schwer zu regeln,
dass die Anbieter auch eine Mindestgeschwindigkeit mit angeben müssen.
Sagen wir mal mindestens 400 Mbit, maximal ein Gigabit.
Und alle sind doch zufrieden.
Noch dazu sollten natürlich auch die Preise angepasst werden.
Wer nämlich nur 400 Mbit erhält, der sollte natürlich auch nur für 400 Mbit zahlen.
Und nicht für ein Gigabit.
Wo ist bitteschön hier der Gesetzgeber?
Diese Taktik gibt es schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Geändert wird aber rein gar nichts.
Und ja, ich rede hier übrigens nur die ganze Zeit vom festgezählten.
Ne, die können jetzt ja nicht einfach ein Gesetz machen, was das ändert.
Ich meine, stellt euch mal vor, die politische Karriere ist zu Ende.
Und man würde sich die Option verbauen, dass man vielleicht in den Aufsichtsrat von einer
Telekom oder von Vodafone könnte.
Also das kann man natürlich, das geht nicht.
Das ist ausgeschlossen.
Im Mobilbereich, da will ich überhaupt gar nicht erst sprechen.
Da sieht es ja noch viel düsterer aus.
Wobei ich hier persönlich die Telekom mal so ein bisschen loben muss.
Denn mit dem Telekom-Netz fahre ich aktuell tatsächlich am besten.
Zu O2-Zeiten.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Die Telekom, so schlecht der Ruf der Telekom auch ist,
die anderen sind noch schlechter.
Man muss der Telekom echt zugutehalten.
Wenn die Telekom was verkauft,
zum größten Teil funktioniert der Kram.
Das Problem, was die Telekom hat,
ähm,
das Problem, was die Telekom hat,
ist,
dass die Technik langsam am Ende ist.
Das, was die Telekom verkauft, funktioniert in der Regel ganz gut.
... irgendwo ein Netz zu haben.
Mit Telekom-LTE kommt es hier tatsächlich nur sehr selten vor,
dass ich mal kein Netz habe.
Also Mobilfunk,
also Mobilfunk muss ich sagen,
da kann ich ihm nur teilweise Recht geben.
Also eins habe ich festgestellt,
vielleicht liegt das auch daran,
jetzt an dem neuen Smartphone,
dass ich mittlerweile ziemlich zuverlässig LTE habe auf meiner Strecke.
Außer in Maintal,
in Maintal-Ost,
da ist regelmäßig alles komplett weg.
Noch nicht mal Edge,
noch nicht mehr Edge.
Das dauert dann so zwei, drei Minuten,
dann ist er irgendwie beim nächsten Mast oder so.
Aber Maintal-Ost ist immer weg.
Alles.
Aber das ist natürlich eine ganz...
Ich meine,
Weltstadt, Maintal-Ost,
ja, da kann das ja mal passieren.
Andere Geschichte.
Und bei noch einer Sache
muss ich die ja eher ungeliebte Telekom sogar nochmal loben,
denn auch wenn man Internet,
so langsam war das Rauchzeichen auf dem Balkon,
eine deutlich bessere Übertragung boten,
Ausfälle gab es wirklich nie.
Das Internet war die ganzen Jahre...
Ich meine die Anschlüsse eben zum Haus.
Dass die Telekom Backend-mäßig ziemlich gut ist,
da habe ich keine Ahnung von,
aber würde ich auch von ausgehen.
Immer bombenstabil,
aber natürlich auch teurer als andere.
Das muss man natürlich dazu sagen.
Ansonsten bin ich von der Telekom aber absolut enttäuscht.
Und ich warte ehrlich gesagt nur noch darauf,
dass die jetzt auch bei uns im Ort hier ankommen
und dann auch noch eine zweite Glasfaserleitung verbuddeln.
Wundern wird es mich definitiv nicht.
Das wäre doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich fände es super,
wenn die Telekom eine zweite Glasfaserleitung bei mir verlegt.
Das wäre dann bei mir zwar die erste,
weil da liegt noch keine,
aber das können die auch.
Aber das können die ruhig machen.
Kriege ich vielleicht auch mal.
Dann gehe ich wieder zur Telekom.
Und das ist der Grund,
warum ich meine Festnetztelefonnummer
zu einem VoIP-Anbieter portiert habe.
Damit ich easy as fuck meinen Internetanbieter wechseln kann.
Bürger würde ich mal sagen eher wenig.
Das ist halt die Sache der Regierung
und der entsprechenden Anbieter.
Es muss mehr und vor allem...
Bürokratisch?
Es muss unbedingt mehr
und vor allem unbürokratisch
Geld des Bundes locker gemacht werden.
Und zwar nicht 1 oder 5 Milliarden,
sondern deutlich mehr.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt,
dass wirklich Geld fehlt
oder dass die Koordination
beziehungsweise der Wille zum Ausbau nicht da ist.
Ist das jetzt nicht einfach.
Aber die gab es vor kurzem ja noch nicht
und die ist natürlich auch irgendwann mal wieder vorbei.
Wie gesagt, unbürokratisch bitte.
Geld wird ja aktuell schon zur Verfügung gestellt.
Nur wenn es niemand abruft,
dann bringt es natürlich auch niemand was.
Die Anbieter müssen in Zukunft
weiterhin auch gewisse Standards erfüllen.
Da sie das natürlich nicht freiwillig machen,
müssen auch hier natürlich Gesetze her.
Es darf nicht mehr auf Kupfer gesetzt werden.
Das reicht mit VDSL aktuell zwar noch aus,
ist aber natürlich nicht zukunftsfähig
und eine Sackgasse mit enormen Kosten.
Denn sobald Kupfer nicht mehr ausreicht,
muss die Glasfaser dann doch bis ins Haus gelegt werden.
Läuft das Team jetzt eigentlich schon?
Läuft das Team jetzt eigentlich ordentlich?
Kann ich die Bitrate wieder ein bisschen hochstellen?
Die kann dann natürlich entsorgt werden.
Es muss auf Glasfaser gesetzt werden.
Da gibt es überhaupt keine Alternative.
Nicht nur für Privatleute,
sondern hauptsächlich für die Wirtschaft.
Und damit natürlich auch uns YouTuber.
Und glaubt mir, YouTube mit meiner alten Telekomleitung,
das war gar nicht lustig.
Du hast ein Gigabit über Kupfer?
Das geht?
Oder besser gesagt,
ist die Kupferleitung 2,50 Meter lang?
Ich wusste bisher gar nicht,
dass es Kupferanschlüsse mit Gigabit noch gibt.
Ja, das ist okay.
Das würde ich nicht als...
Kupfer ist für mich das alte
Zweitrad-Kupferleitungs-Ding von der Telekom.
Dass die Coax-Kabel vom Fernseher,
vom Kabelnetz,
dass da letztendlich auch Kupfer
oder irgendein Metall drin ist.
Ja, aber das zählt bei mir nicht als Kupferleitung.
... auch eingehalten werden.
Wenn ich ein Gigabit bestelle,
dann muss sich das auch erhalten.
Ansonsten muss der Anbieter...
Bis 100 Meter geht das.
Nee, das sind nur zwei Leitungen.
Über zwei Leitungen machst du das nicht so ohne weiteres.
Über zwei Adern.
Ungeschirmte, ungeschirmte Adern
irgendwo in einem Haus, die da rumfliegen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man ein Gigabit
verlässlich über mehr als ein paar Meter
über zwei Kupferadern kriegt.
Anders geht es nicht.
Ja, und zum Abschluss noch ein bisschen
was Positives, das ich loswerden möchte,
denn ja, das Internet in Deutschland,
das ist scheiße.
Da brauchen wir überhaupt nicht drüber reden.
Keine Diskussion.
Aber wer kritisiert,
muss natürlich auch einige positive Dinge nennen.
Muss man.
Das Internet ist scheiße.
Reicht.
Bäm.
Denn so langsam das Netz in Deutschland ist,
es scheint aber ziemlich stabil zu sein.
Ja, hat man heute gesehen.
Hat man heute gesehen.
Also der einzige positive Punkt bei mir,
was Internet auch ist, ist,
was Internetausbau in Deutschland angeht,
ist, wir sind noch nicht die Allerletzten,
aber wir sind auf dem Weg dahin.
Gut.
Andere Länder, die stöhnen ja aktuell
über die hohe Datenlast,
während man sich in Deutschland fragt,
wo ist überhaupt das Problem?
Denn Probleme gibt es hier wirklich keine großen.
Was vielleicht natürlich auch irgendwie
mit der schwachen Internetverbindung
zu tun haben könnte.
Trotzdem, in der Hinsicht ein Lob an unser Internet.
Aber nur ein ganz, ganz, ganz kleines,
denn der Rest, der ist einfach scheiße.
Ja, ich gebe,
also ich würde es nicht bei allem zustimmen,
aber bei dem Grundtenor würde ich mich anschließen,
habe ich ja auch schon mich in ein paar Videos
darüber ausgelassen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal,
ob ich die Bandbreite wieder hochstellen kann,
ob das Ganze dann noch funktioniert.
Oh fuck, Leak, Leute, Leak.
Stream Settings, Leak, Leak.
Überall, überall Leaks.
So, stellen wir mal wieder hoch auf 4,9.
Okay, Stats.
Set.
Ha, das scheint gerade zu funktionieren.
Den Stream Key kann man gar nicht mal einblenden.
Im Stream, das haben sie gut gemacht.
Gears Tactics, oh, juckt mich eigentlich nicht wirklich an.
Ist was für den Frasier.
Also, wollen wir nochmal zur ursprünglichen Frage
ganz am Anfang vom Stream kommen.
Hat irgendjemand einen guten Kalender,
was Technik-Events für das jeweilige Jahr angeht?
Weil ich würde mir gerne mal wieder ein paar Präsentationen,
Keynotes, sonstiges Gedöns angucken.
Erstens, um danach ein bisschen abzulästern,
was gezeigt wird.
Und außerdem, weil ich es immer ganz interessant finde,
das mit dem Chat zusammen anzugucken.
Hat er irgendeinen guten Kalender,
wo man so die ganzen Events sieht?
Keine Ahnung, wann hat Apple wieder was Neues?
Wann hat Microsoft irgendeine Konferenz?
Wann ist...
Gut, Gamescom und Geschiss fällt ja aus,
aber sowas.
Hat da irgendjemand eine gute Seite,
wo man die ganzen Events sieht?
Am besten halt auch mit EU-Zeiten.
Also jetzt nicht, die nur NA-Zeiten haben.
Mnet in München baut G-Fast.
Also Klingeldraht vom Keller bis Wohnung.
Okay, Keller bis Wohnung mag noch funktionieren.
Je nachdem, wie hoch das Haus ist.
Computerwelt-AT-Events.
Jetzt kommen die Österreicher auch noch.
Schweizer hatten wir heute schon am Start.
Jetzt kommen noch die Österreicher am Start.
Jetzt sind wir hier richtig international,
zumindest deutschsprachig.
Was ist das?
Äh...
C++-Move-Semantik.
Oh!
Das sind eher irgendwelche Offline-Events,
die man buchen kann, oder?
Weniger Events, wo Livestreams gehalten werden.
Das ist eher so ein Konferenz-Event,
so ein Konferenz-Teilnehmer-Kalender,
wo man sich anmelden kann.
Serverless.
Ja, das war schon ganz schön Buzzword-heavy.
So.
10 Minutes Know-How...
Was ist das für ein Satz?
10 Minuten Know-How-Break.
Ach, das ist eine...
Das ist eine Pause, in der man was lernt, oder was?
Serverless Computing Edge Computing Gateways.
Das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Ich brauch...
Ich brauch einen ordentlichen Kalender.
IT...
IT-Event-Kalender.
Gibt's da vielleicht...
Muss ich mal kurz danach suchen.
IT-Event-Kalender 2020.
Schon mal was mit AWS Lambda gemacht?
Nee, tatsächlich noch gar nicht.
Mit AWS...
Also...
AWS hab ich noch...
Noch...
Ich überleg grad, ob ich AWS überhaupt...
Ich glaub, AWS hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Das einzige, was ich bisher verwendet hab, ist Google...
Google-Dings, wo ich mir immer den Namen nicht merken kann.
Die Google-Cloud-Plattform, die sie da haben.
Und Azure.
Azure.
Sag mir mal eine, eine 10-stellige Primzahl.
What the fuck?
Woher soll mir das jetzt aus dem Kopf wissen?
Wobei man das wahrscheinlich relativ, relativ einfach, äh...
Googeln kann, oder?
Kann man nicht googeln?
Was?
Muss man doch googeln können.
Das kann man ja sogar noch relativ...
Das kann man ja sogar noch einfach...
Relativ einfach selbst ausrechnen.
Also, nicht im Kopf.
Außer man ist wahnsinnig big brain, sondern...
In nem Programm.
10-stellig ist ja nur wirklich nicht so viel.
Äh, äh, was?
Nee, nee.
Wie viel, wie viel Stellen?
Doch, 10 Stellen.
Das ist doch nicht viel, 10 Stellen.
Eats.
Ähm...
Ja, sowas hier bräuchte man, genau.
Ja, so ein Kalender mein ich doch.
Sowas, sowas brauchen wir.
Wo ist denn immer...
Die Bixby Developer Sessions.
Siehste?
Dank dem Stream am Sonntag weiß ich jetzt auch, was Bixby ist.
Bixby war der...
Was war das?
Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Samsung Voice Assistant oder sowas?
Was?
Samsung?
Ja.
Samsung Siri.
Jo.
Ähm, mal gucken, was ich für, für Questions hier wieder übersehen hab.
Kannst du mal kurz wissen...
Was?
Nein.
Also, was kommt als nächstes?
Kann ich an Hallo Welt in Kobol?
Nee, stimmt, das wär eigentlich...
Das erinnert mich an was.
Wir wollten uns mal Kobol im Stream angucken.
Di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di-di...
Äh, okay.
Geotactics...
Ja, das ist...
Wir als Deutsche sind leicht zufrieden zu stellen, damit dafür sind wir ganz schön viele am Meckern immer...
Habt ihr eigentlich eure Maske heut' aufgehabt, Leute?
Habt ihr damit alle eure Maske aufgehabt?
Ich nicht.
Weil ich bin nicht aus'm Haus gegangen.
Haus gegangen.
War nicht draußen. Okay, Leute. Ich sehe,
ich sehe, wir verstehen uns.
Wir verstehen uns.
Wir sind noch in Amsterdam am Flug. Oh, was?
Das ist Baro hier.
On Tour.
Ach, die Masken sind in Amsterdam.
Ich ganz sicher nicht.
Warum nicht? Hätte doch mal sein können.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht fährst du mit dem Physik
Grill mal nach Amsterdam.
Hallo, Sir of Jelly.
Äh, was?
Wieso ist eigentlich Carlinux
das Go-To-OS für Hackermans, weil da viel
dabei ist?
Moment, das hatten wir doch alle schon.
Das hatten wir doch alle schon.
Erstmal ganz Questions löschen.
Was du für ein Smartphone
bevorzugst? Ja, das war, da wollte ich vorhin noch
kurz was zu sagen. Also, wie gesagt, ich habe
jede Menge Android-Tablets. Ich habe
iPads und ich habe halt nur
iPhones tatsächlich als Smartphones
bisher gehabt und ich habe mir halt noch nie eins gekauft.
Wenn ich mir eins kaufen würde, würde ich mir vielleicht auch
ein Android kaufen, aber aktuell ist es so,
dass ich die letzten drei Smartphones, inklusive dem
aktuellen, von der Firma bekommen habe,
wo ich arbeite und
die Dinger taugen.
Dementsprechend
habe ich da keinen Anreiz, irgendwie was
Neues zu kaufen. Ach, das Physik-Grill
ist schon vergeben.
Oh, Sibaro, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Paper Hands.
Was sagst du zum
Fairphone? Lange nichts mehr
gehört von.
Ich finde, das ist an sich ein gutes Projekt. Ich habe
bloß das Gefühl,
beziehungsweise ich glaube,
weil ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist,
dass das keine
kein
großartiger Erfolg wird,
weil die Leute halt
lieber, sagen wir mal,
die Hälfte für ausgeben
mit gleichwertigen Features.
Das war aber schon ewig her. Ich wusste
gar nicht, ob es das Fairphone überhaupt schon gibt mittlerweile.
Ich habe da mal vor fünf Jahren oder so in der CT
was drüber gelesen. Ich bin ja so ausgesprochen,
ich habe immer noch ein CT-Abo.
Ich habe seit
20 Jahren oder so ein CT-Abo.
Ich habe hier
einen Stapel CTs, der ist
ohne Mist von der Erde bis zur Decke
in der Ecke vom Zimmer. Und ich gucke
da nie rein.
Boomer. Richtig Boomer.
Meine Eltern
haben sich einen neuen Fernseher gekauft,
an dem alten Fernseher
war ein Raspberry Pi dran.
Meine Eltern wundern sich, warum
sie keine Internetseiten aufmachen
können. Auf dem Pi war ein Pi-Hall.
Hä?
Den Zusammenhang
verstehe ich nicht.
Oh, das ist eine Frage, die kommt oft.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin nicht der große Pro, was Desktop-PC-Komponenten
angeht. Ich kenne mich damit immer nur aus,
wenn, ähm,
wenn ich mir selbst was kaufen will.
Ich dachte, die haben den Strom
vom Pi weggemacht hier dann.
Ich wollte mir dieses Jahr einen PC zusammenstellen
und wollte dich nun fragen, ob du an
meiner Stelle noch mit den Komponenten warten würdest,
wie Grafikkarte und so weiter, auf die neue PC-Komponente.
wie Grafikkarte und so weiter, auf die neue PC-Komponente. Wie Grafikkarte und so weiter, auf die neue PC-Komponente.
Wie Grafikkarte und so weiter, auf die neue PC-Komponente.
Ja, wenn es nicht eilt, würde ich warten. Tatsächlich.
Ähm, aber wenn du sagst,
ich will jetzt unbedingt einen neuen PC, weil ich irgendwas nicht
spielen kann oder mir es auf den Sack geht, dass mein Alter
so langsam ist, dann würde ich es jetzt gleich kaufen.
Warten lohnt in der Regel nicht,
wenn man, wenn man jetzt akut Bedarf
an neuer Hardware hat. Ansonsten,
wenn es nicht so akut ist, dann kannst du warten.
Ich habe ja auch gewartet. Ich war letztes
Jahr kurz davor,
mir einen Ryzen-PC zusammenzustellen,
der absolut sinnlos gewesen
wäre, weil ich einen Rechner habe,
der immer noch schneller ist als 95%
aller anderen Rechner. Aber
ich war kurz davor.
Aber ich habe es dann trotzdem sein gelassen.
Hehe.
Hat das damals für
ASCII-Porn gereicht?
Ich glaube, sowas gab es damals nicht.
Was? Die Schweiz
wie viele andere sind Fake-Gut.
Was man in der Krise gut gesehen hat.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was
an der Schweiz Fake-Gut ist,
ähm, wenn die sagen, es gibt
ein Gigabit-Internet und es funktioniert.
Das ist ja kein Fake.
Das geht dann halt.
Hoffentlich merken die Politiker, dass das Internet stark
genutzt wird, sie Corona-Zeiten.
Also, wenn die erst Corona dafür brauchen,
um zu merken, dass das Internet gebraucht wird,
dann würde das tatsächlich
unseren Ausbau erklären, ja.
Jeder, der will, kann eine
Direkt-Anbindung haben und das ist nicht teuer
für Firmen. Kommt drauf.
Naja, also, weiß nicht, ob das
nicht teuer ist.
Also, ja, wenn du jetzt eine Firma bist, die übelst viel
Fettkohle hat, mit Sicherheit.
Aber ich weiß, was wir für unsere 2 Gigabit-Anbindung
Ja, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Was wir für unsere 2 Gigabit
Dark-Fiber-Leitung, wobei
es sind sogar mehr mittlerweile als 2 Gigabit,
bezahlen und das ist doch schon ordentlich.
Was kostet's denn?
Was kostet's denn? Mal angenommen,
ich hab wirklich eine Firma,
die, wo nicht
einfach quasi
in der Nähe schon irgendwo was liegt,
wo man was abzweigen kann,
sondern wo wirklich was hingelegt werden muss.
Ich glaub nicht, dass das so
so mal nebenbei
easy money ist.
Kennst du eine gute Möglichkeit, Sound von
2 Geräten oder VM und Host
zu mixen, um
2 Sourcen gleichzeitig zu hören?
Ja.
Zum Beispiel bei einer VM mit virtualisiertem
Sound habe ich immer noch Crackling.
Also das Beste, was du machen kannst für
ordentlichen Sound in einer VM,
ist eine USB-Soundkarte.
Da reicht auch eine ganz
billige, das ist besser
als diese ganze VMWare
emulierte Soundkarten
Gedöns.
Nimm eine USB-Soundkarte,
irgendeine billige USB-Soundkarte von Amazon,
irgendwas,
okay, das muss ja nicht vielleicht,
nimm irgendwas, das ist auf jeden Fall besser als
das VMWare emulierte Zeug
und
mach hier
USB-Weiterleitung
in die VM
und dann holst du dir,
das würde ich eh jedem empfehlen, der mehr als
eine Audio-Source
hat, da holst du dir irgendeinen ganz kleinen
Mixer für kleines
Geld
und mischt das
zusammen. Da kannst du dann auch schön
dein Kopfhörer dran machen,
da hast du den Sound dann auch getrennt
von, je nachdem, wenn du mehrere Rechner hast, von
Konsole, vom Arbeitsrechner, vom
Spielrechner, vielleicht noch TS, anders.
Gute, gute Ryzen-Mainboards,
kein Schimmer.
Äh, was sagt er hier?
Gerade mit...
Es, naja, man muss
ja mal sagen, also,
je nachdem, was
es für eine Firma ist,
ist das nicht viel.
Je nachdem, was das für eine Firma ist,
ist das nicht viel. Aber
natürlich, insgesamt betrachtet
ist es schon ordentlich teuer.
Was Morddrohungen trennt, warum
trennt Morddrohungen?
Mögen die Leute Barbara Schöneberger
beim Computerspielepreis nicht?
Was?
Morddrohungen gegen Virologe.
Die Leute haben echt einen kompletten Dachschaden.
Die Leute sind echt
immer ganz dicht, Alter.
Was für ein günstiger Mixer?
Also,
der kleine Yamaha-Mixer
ist ziemlich gut.
War das der?
Wenn es den noch eins kleiner gibt, dann kann man
auch den eins kleiner nehmen.
Ja, der da ist ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch der
aktuellste ist, da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich kann auch gleich den nehmen.
Der hat noch ein bisschen mehr Eingänge.
Ähm, der ist
ganz gut. Wie viele
Spuren, oh, da musst du mal auf die Seite gucken bei
denen, ich würde sagen drei.
Drei oder vier?
Zwei? Drei, hä?
Ich würde mal vermuten drei?
Sieht etwas overkill aus.
Warum?
Das ist super, das Teil.
Du verwendest ja nicht alles.
Der Vorteil
bei diesen kleinen ist,
ähm,
auch bei den kleinen Mixern von
Behringer, ich weiß, dass Behringer nicht den
besten Ruf hat in Audiokreisen, aber
für so ein bisschen, wir mixen ein paar Sachen daheim
zusammen, äh, um es über
Kopfhörer zu hören, ist das jetzt nicht so
wild, ähm,
die kleinen Dinger
haben den Vorteil, die haben noch
Anschlüsse für
ein 3,5 mm
Headset-Mikrofon.
Das haben die größeren, besseren
Mixer alle nicht, das heißt,
dafür sind die Dinger ganz gut.
Ansonsten braucht ihr irgendeinen Adapter.
Und da gibt's gar nicht
so viele. Ja.
Ja, die, ich hab auch
hier, ich hab auch den, den allen kleinsten
Behringer-Mixer, heute würde ich mir aber den da
kaufen, oder vielleicht sogar den.
Also ich würde den vorziehen,
der hat ein bisschen mehr Funktionen
als das Behringer-Ding.
Also ich hab ja, ich hab ja zwei
Sachen. Ich hab einmal mein
Moto Sound, äh, USB-Audio
Interface, mit dem ich nahezu alles
mache, das hat 16 Spuren.
Und, ähm, für Headset,
für das Headset-Mikro,
und, ähm, die Xbox
hab ich noch so einen kleinen
300 irgendwie, so ein ganz kleines
Furz-Mixer-Ding.
Für 50 Euro.
Scheint mir die zweite Auflage zu sein,
das sieht ein bisschen anders aus als meiner.
Wobei, nee, das ist der,
aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
heute würde ich mir, würde ich mir den kaufen.
Äh,
ich benutze den in
meinem Audio-Interface.
Ich hab den Rechner per
Toslink-Kabel am Audio-Interface
dran, und
hab das, äh, hab den Kopfhörer
auch am Audio-Interface dran, und da ist ja
natürlich ein digitaler
Road-Converter und auch ein Verstärker drin.
Das hört sich eigentlich ganz gut an. Ähm,
VoiceMeter hab ich auch mal
benutzt, aber
VoiceMeter hat, äh, Verzögerung.
Weil wahrscheinlich
Software und weil wahrscheinlich Windows.
Das machen eigentlich gerade so
die Zahlen,
die weltweiten Corona-Zahlen. Ah!
Excellent!
Das Kokona-Land hat's geschafft.
Haben sie jetzt mehr als die restliche Welt zusammen?
Nee, nicht ganz, oder?
Hell yeah!
Es tut mir da schon für die Leute ein bisschen leid.
Gerade, gerade die, denen's halt so
schon nicht gut geht.
Ähm, die kriegen's da jetzt halt richtig ab.
Aber Freiheit, genau.
Kannst ja auf Twitter rumkacken.
Ja, es lohnt sich nicht.
NetCologne hat einen super Ruf. Das stimmt.
Tatsächlich. Da hab ich
wenig, ähm,
Schlechtes drüber gehört.
Aber die sind ja auch nicht ganz
deutschlandweit aktiv, oder, NetCologne?
Wer auch einen ganz guten
Ruf früher hat, war HanseNet.
Das ist das, was dann zu Alice wurde. Und ich weiß nicht,
wer Alice gekauft hat.
Wer hat Alice, wer hat Alice gekauft?
Guck mal, Webmail gibt's noch.
Alice DS... Oh, O2.
United Internet wahrscheinlich,
ja.
Mein Alice DSL.
Oh.
Aber Webmail 7.0 Login gibt's noch.
Ja, ich hab mein Passwort
vergessen. HanseNet, genau.
Wo sind wir da?
Wie sieht eigentlich so der Trend bei uns aus,
seitdem wir's aufgemacht haben? Man sieht's ja
nicht so richtig, weil das ja zwei, drei Wochen
verzögert kommt.
Aber zumindest die USA geht gut ab.
Das Video hat viele falsche
Infos, okay.
Das hatten wir vorhin schon.
Was? Echt?
Okay.
Hast du so ne schwierige Hausnummer,
dass die's nicht finden?
Ja, das hatten wir grad, wie gesagt, USB,
Soundkarte.
Nein, kenn ich nicht.
Hatten wir grade.
Oh, ey, haben wir doch bei uns auch.
Haben wir doch bei uns auch.
Da gab's doch letztens den Typ, der erzählt
hat, ähm, ja, ich weiß
auch nicht, was die Regierung davon hat,
jetzt die Wirtschaft, äh, dass die Wirtschaft
den Bach runter geht, aber das muss was
mit neuer Weltordnung zu tun haben.
Das hab ich auch gedacht.
Excellent.
Big Brain.
Wenn dann nix mehr einfällt,
dann muss das was mit neuer Weltordnung zu tun haben.
Natürlich.
5G-Maßnahmen. Warum die sich alle so auf
5G da teilweise
einschießen, leuchtet mir überhaupt
nicht ein.
Ich mein, das einzige, was die Leute
ja nicht checken, ist, es gibt
Länder, so wie China
zum Beispiel, die haben halt keinen Bock,
Schlusslicht zu sein, wie wir, was Internetausbau
und Mobilfunkausbau angeht. Ja, die haben auch schon
5G. Das ist ja unvorstellbar.
Das hier ist perfekt.
Was, ein Smoothie-Maker?
Excellent.
Oh.
So nen Smoothie-Maker, da könnt ich, ich könnt mal,
ich könnt wirklich wieder nen Smoothie-Maker gebrauchen, weil,
meine ist kaputt.
Kopier mich eins.
Okay, weil du's bist, Tobi.
Achtung, das hier
ist die Eins aus dem Twitch-Chat.
Das ist nicht irgendeine Eins.
Das ist DIE Eins.
Poggers.
Was ist das?
Corona-Proteste.
Das, der, der sieht,
der sieht schon,
der sieht wirklich aus,
der sieht wirklich aus.
Der sieht original Kokona aus,
der Typ, Alter.
Mehr Kokona kannst du nicht aussehen.
Guckt euch mal an,
hinten der Typ da in der, mit der Kamera
am Startkleid.
Okay, was,
was hat er für Schmerzen?
I put that at risk today.
Cause I gotta be here.
Guck mal, wie durchgeweicht, wie durchgeweicht die Maske ist.
Are you scared to die?
No more scared than I am for anything else.
FREEDOM!
Alter, die Abis.
Alter, die,
eieieieiei.
How many?
Three or four.
How many does Disney own?
How many? I don't know.
You're in the media, are you?
Yeah, but I'm independent.
Independent what?
Independent media.
Wie, was, sowas gibt's?
You're fat.
Hahaha, recht.
Ist das, ist das wirklich,
ist das wirklich alles vom gleichen Protest?
Manches sieht so reingeschnitten aus.
Manches sieht so reingeschnitten aus, irgendwie.
I will take a chance to get a
Coronavirus, whether, better than
shutting down this economy.
I'll die on my feet, not on my knees.
Yeah, I want you to take the vaccine first, Bill Gates.
Der arme Bill Gates, was kann der denn dafür?
Bill Gates hat ja wirklich mal
vor ein paar Jahren
einen TED-Talk gehalten
zum Thema Epidemie und
Virus und sowas.
Wahrscheinlich kommen sie daher,
dass Bill Gates
Warum ausgerechnet Bill Gates?
If you understand,
this is China's wet dream
to hurt our nation. It's their wet dream.
And this is about our liberty, brother.
Who do you think agenda this is?
Oh, er hustet.
Die Amis, Alter!
For a long lock down, basically
slavery. Do you feel enslaved?
I do. I'm a type A
lawyer and I'm bouncing off the walls
of my living room because I can't go out.
California, not communism.
Everybody cough in my face.
Die haben echt einen Dachschaden, Alter.
Ja, ich glaub's dir.
Fake.
Fake Death Numbers. Warum sollte denn irgendein Land Fake Death Numbers rausgeben?
Mit jedem Tod, der steigt, bedeutet das doch nur, dass was nicht richtig gelaufen ist.
Okay.
Okay, China gibt tatsächlich Fake Numbers raus, aber nicht wirklich Fake Death Numbers, sondern Fake Numbers.
Fucking touch anything and everything, it makes your immune system stronger.
I used to be afraid of raw eggs and raw meat, and now I drink raw eggs, and I eat raw meat, and I have been for years, and I'm fucking fine.
Every conspiracy I've pretty much ever heard of is all pretty much true.
9-11 was an inside job.
Oh, jetzt geht das los.
The vaccines are poison.
Can you cough in my face?
Oh Gott, da haben sie ja gerade den richtigen am Start, ey.
See, people are too, they're too sick.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch, dass der, wo ist der 5G-Mast?
Ich weiß, ich weiß, wir haben in Deutschland, haben wir auch mittlerweile sowas.
Ich hab's, ich hab letztens auch noch ein paar Sachen aus Deutschland gesehen.
Scared to even cough when you ask them to.
We don't have a civil right to be immortal.
If only the healthy people are okay, and the people who are at risk get ill, isn't that how it's supposed to be?
I mean, we are teaching fear, not courage.
I call it the original name.
The 2019 NCOV, because it's not the SARS.
Oh, oh, oh, New World Order, da haben wir es wieder.
Kennst du den Typ nicht?
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Statistically, it's political science.
We have to be able to protect our posterity.
Pros, pros, posterity.
Be, invade, increase, that's not how I...
Oh, das ist ja, verdammt, das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Dass es große Wellen gibt und man jetzt nicht surfen kann.
Also wirklich jetzt.
That pisses me off.
Barefoot out here.
Well, everyone's accusing everybody of everything, so I wore my Bernie shirt, so I can stand with a Trump supporter all day, please.
So what's a son mean?
It means my family helped build the underground railroad, just like the Italians.
I don't know...
Ich verstehe die manchmal überhaupt nicht.
Also, ich mein, das mag am Dialekt liegen, aber ich verstehe auch auf den Demos, wenn Deutsche interviewt werden, teilweise die Leute nicht.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus wirrem Gerede und irgendwie Genusche.
Und oftmals, da verstehe ich es überhaupt nicht schwer.
What does this have to do with the lockdown?
Because it's government-issued.
Warum befragen die immer nur solche Experten?
Ich vermute da zwei Gründe.
Erstens, weil es dort ziemlich viele solche Experten gibt.
Und zweitens, und das darf man bei solchen Berichten nie aus Acht lassen, weil es sich gut macht für das Video.
Und man kann natürlich mit der passenden Auswahl der Interviewpartner,
der Leute, die man zeigt und interviewt, auch Berichte in eine gewisse Wirkung lenken, wie so ein Bericht hat.
Aber ich vermute mal, dass dort halt auch der Anteil solcher Spezialisten ziemlich hoch ist.
Was hat der Spanische Slough mit allem zu tun?
Was ist der Plan?
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Wie er fragt was.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Was geht?
Was haben die denn da?
Irgendwelche Buffalo-Hörner oder sowas?
Die Wand von Jericho wird da...
Ah, ist klar.
Ey, oh Gott.
Natürlich.
Aber wir müssen sein können.
Also der Erdbeere-Kombination ist die einzige essenzielle.
Gott liebt Amerika!
Die Welt der Erden!
Leute, wie lange geht das noch?
Eine Minute, ok?
Eine Minute halte ich das noch aus.
Was ist der Lieblingsfilm von dir?
Lieblingsfilm?
Empire Strikes Back, aber Viva Vendetta ist in meinen Top 10.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wem ist der Po?
Was?
Wo?
Die WHO.
Die World Health Organization ist die Hauptorganisation für den Jennings vor, weil...
Deswegen, sie, die Welt, angewiesen ist, um die Menschen.
Aber warum?
Oh, Rap-Rap-Gott.
Haha, natürlich.
Alle die Amis, ich kann mir das nicht weiter angucken.
Dazu muss man aber sagen, wir haben auch genug Verrückte in der Richtung.
Also, wie gesagt, letztens wieder was gesehen, wo dann einer am Ende sich hingestellt hat,
ja, ich weiß auch nicht, woran das liegt, aber neue Weltordnung muss es sein.
Ich hab einfach gedacht, oh, Facepalm, Facepalm.
Also, es ist ja legitim, ja, es ist ja vollkommen legitim, wenn man sich fragt,
wie weit man was mitmachen will.
Also sprich, wenn man sagt, hey, welche Maßnahmen sind für mich akzeptabel
und welche Maßnahmen sind für mich nicht akzeptabel.
Das ist ja vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn man sich das fragt.
Aber aktuell, bis auf die Unfähigkeit mit ihrer Corona-App,
die ich mir im Leben so nicht installieren werde,
und mit Sicherheit wieder,
sich versuche, dauerhafte Überwachungssachen zu etablieren,
unter dem Deckmantel von, wir wollen die Leute beschützen,
also sprich, wir brauchen irgendwie mehr Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
wir brauchen mehr Kameras, wir brauchen sonst was.
Sowas sind sie ja immer schneller am Start, was das angeht.
Finde ich, die Maßnahmen, die aktuell getroffen werden,
zu 99 Prozent eigentlich vollkommen gerechtfertigt und in Ordnung.
Da kann man doch eigentlich gar nichts Großartiges dagegen sagen.
Was ich ja persönlich viel lustiger finde, ist,
dass man am Anfang erzählt,
Masken bringen nix.
Ähm, wartet mal kurz.
Komische Messages hier.
Ja, also was ich ja persönlich viel lustiger finde, ist,
was wir am Anfang erzählt haben,
die Masken bringen nix.
Und das klingt für mich, klang für mich auch alles irgendwie recht nachvollziehbar.
Wenn man gesagt hat, ja okay,
wenn man selbst ansteckend ist,
dass man nicht so viel Zeug in die Welt reinhustet, bringt das was.
Bei allen anderen Sachen ist es jetzt nicht so,
dass das wahnsinnig viel bringt.
Vielleicht hält es ein bisschen auf.
Aber eine große Prägen ist es nicht.
Das klang alles, klang alles sehr,
sehr nachvollziehbar.
Und damals hieß es ja auch,
also damals ist es eineinhalb Monate, von einem Monat her,
ähm, äh,
ihr sagt immer, ja, Masken könnt ihr euch eigentlich schenken,
müsst ihr gar nicht kaufen, totaler Schwachsinn,
brauchen wir nicht. Und jetzt,
wo es keine Masken mehr gibt, beziehungsweise
sie ultra teuer sind, heißt
alle Masken aufziehen.
Bringt was, wenn du eine hast, die die Augen bedeckt?
Ja, hab ich, hab ich. Und ich bin ja froh,
dass ich eine gekauft hab.
Weil jetzt hat sich das Geld wenigstens gelohnt,
jetzt wo Maskenpflicht ist.
Jetzt hat sich das wenigstens gelohnt, das Geld auszugeben.
Ja.
Äh, kann man sich überhaupt, klar,
klar, Schleimhäute,
aller Art. Bei manchen Stellen
ist es halt einfacher.
Als ob so damit, ich geh damit raus.
Also ich bin noch nicht damit raus, ich wollte heute eigentlich mal gucken,
ob die mich bei der Bank, ähm,
bei der Bank Geld abheben
lassen damit, aber ich geh da, wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich
mal raus, ich geh damit mal raus. Mal gucken, mal gucken, was die Leute machen.
Ähm.
So, das fand ich lustig, dass
alle am Anfang gesagt haben, oh nö, bringt nix.
Und jetzt auf einmal, ah, Maske, Maske, Maske.
Und, was ich ja persönlich jetzt
auch irgendwie witzig finde,
ähm,
da muss ich jetzt
immer aufpassen, man muss ja mittlerweile teilweise echt
extrem aufpassen, wie man Sachen formuliert,
ja, sonst kommt gleich wieder einer.
Ich weiß noch, wo ich im Video mal was
gesagt hab, ähm,
irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was ich wählen soll, bla bla bla,
und da kam der erste, Max, ruf zum AfD-Wählen auf.
Ja, die Leute sind immer so
mega schnell am Start, irgendwas in den falschen Hals zu kriegen
und sich über irgendwas aufzuringen.
Ähm.
Was ich, was ich ja, was ich ja ganz
merkwürdig finde, ist,
bevor die Corona-Geschichte
angeht, und, und ich glaube halt, da ist
ein gewisses, ein gewisses System dahinter,
weil man versucht, Geld abzugreifen,
ähm, und zwar,
bevor die
Corona-Geschichte
losgegangen ist,
dann haben wir überall, bei allen,
bei allen Möglichkeiten, wo es drum ging,
hat man gesagt, ah, also, in Deutschland,
da haben wir jetzt so viel Geld,
wir können ja fast alles, alles machen, wir können,
wir können auf der Welt, also,
wir können, wir müssen quasi die Welt retten,
wir haben so viel Geld, wir können uns alles leisten,
wobei, da hatten wir es ja letztens im Stream schon von,
ähm, dass, wenn man mal
die Ärmsten und Reichsten weglässt,
im Durchschnitt Leute gar nicht so viel Geld haben, aber wir haben so viel Geld,
wir können alles machen, so. Und jetzt,
ein Monat, Corona,
Stillstand, wir sind pleite.
Der Sprung ging
ganz schön schnell, oder?
Ich meine, wenn man so viel
Geld hat, dass man so ultra
reich ist und so viel Geld und allen,
quasi alles, alles damit finanzieren möchte,
und nach einem Monat pleite
ist, stellt sich doch die Frage,
vielleicht hatte man gar nicht
genug Geld, von Anfang an.
Weil ich, ich verstehe auch nicht,
wie es sein kann, dass es Unternehmen,
oder dass es so viele Unternehmen gibt,
die jahrelang
fetteste Kohle
gemacht haben.
Jetzt nicht nur wie teilweise früher Amazon,
Geld eingenommen und direkt
wieder irgendwo reingesteckt, sondern fette Gewinne
gemacht haben und
nach einem Monat jetzt sagen, Alter, wir brauchen
Staatshilfe. Oder Adidas,
war das Adidas, oder war das, war das,
war das, nein, es war Adidas.
Wir können unsere Miete nicht mehr bezahlen.
So irgendwie nach zwei Wochen, nach zwei Wochen
kam Adidas an, ja, nee, wir können unsere Miete nicht
bezahlen. Wie passt
das denn zusammen?
Wie kann man denn jahrelang ultra
fett Kohle machen, nach zwei Monaten die Miete
nicht mehr bezahlen können?
Ja, es waren nur 82 Milliarden, wo wir,
wie kann man das, wie soll man damit
auch die Miete bezahlen können nach zwei Monaten?
Ja, das, das leuchtet mir nicht so ganz ein,
wie man von, wir sind so reich,
dass wir quasi der ganzen Welt
mit unserem Reichtum helfen können, zu
in einem Monat, wir sind pleite
gekommen sind.
Magst du bist dick? Boah, no shit.
Ähm, das, das
läuft, das leuchtet mir nicht ganz
ein. Ähm,
man hat ja auch gesehen, dass da ganz
schön versucht wird, zu faken.
Und zwar,
ich weiß nicht, habt ihr das mitgekriegt,
mit den, äh, dass
es ein paar Scammer gegeben
hat, die Fake-Namen generiert
haben, die sich deutsch angehört haben und damit
Corona-Hilfe beantragt haben?
Das war in NRW, ja, kann
sein. Ist Kim Jong-Un
wirklich tot? Kein Schimmer.
Ja, natürlich ist das richtig asozial.
Aber ich gehe auch davon
aus, dass, dass andere
Sachen in Richtung, wir müssen, können uns
diese Miete nicht mal bezahlen. Oh, wir brauchen
Corona-Hilfe hier und da.
Dass da auch
viel
schön zurecht gerückt
ist, dass man jetzt Geld bekommt.
Weil anders, da kann ich es mir nicht erklären,
wie man, wie man nach einem Monat
quasi darauf angewiesen
ist, weil man jahrelang fett Kohle
gemacht hat. Wem es wirklich
schlecht geht,
wem es wirklich schlecht geht, und das kann
ich nachvollziehen,
das ist beispielsweise
dem Restaurant hier bei uns auf
der Straße, ja, dem geht es schlecht.
Oder irgendwelchen kleineren Online-Shops.
Oder
dem Bäcker.
Denen geht es wirklich scheiße und das kann ich
nachvollziehen.
Und das ist da, wo es
meiner Meinung nach auch die Hilfen für bräuchte.
Kultur, Kreativ, Gastronomie,
ja genau, denen geht es wirklich scheiße.
Friseur, genau sowas in der Richtung.
Denen geht es wirklich scheiße.
Und ob es da
die einmalige Corona-Hilfe jetzt bringt,
habe ich meine Zweifel.
Ich weiß nicht, was man da so kriegt. Vielleicht sollte ich mich auch mal bewerben.
Weil muss ich ja mal
lohnen, dass ich eine Firma habe.
Ein Unternehmen. Firma ist ja nur der Name.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal
Corona-Hilfe beantragen.
Das harte Influencer-Life
ist ganz schön brutal geworden.
Kommt nichts mehr rum. Es braucht
Corona-Hilfe.
Hast du eine GmbH oder eine UG? Weder noch.
Bis zu 5000 Euro,
wenn du keine Mitarbeiter hast.
Excellent, da werde ich doch mal morgen gleich den Antrag raushauen.
Auf geht's.
Und
also ich bin ja bei weitem nicht
der Wirtschafts-Pro. Das ist ja ein Thema, was mich nicht
großartig interessiert.
Aber was ich mich auch frage
ist, wenn jetzt so
welche ankommen, wie sagen wir mal Lufthansa oder so
und dann kommen sie an mit irgendwie
10 Milliarden, sonst was, Rettungsprogramm.
Gerade so riesig fette
Firmen und so riesig fette Unternehmen.
Die jahrelang am Start waren,
äh, nicht am Start,
am Start gewesen sind, also
aktiv waren.
Wenn die nicht genug Reserven haben, um
quasi
einen Monat irgendwie zu,
bei Lufthansa Drift halt hat es, geht halt grad nix,
aber trotzdem.
Da frage ich mich, ob vorher auch alles in Ordnung
gewesen ist.
Wenn das nach einem Monat da schon so düster aussieht.
Ich hab mal bei uns
mit einem externen
äh
Energie-Mensch geredet.
Also sprich einer, der nicht fest bei uns angestellt ist,
sondern nur für ein Projekt da ist.
Und der hat auch gesagt, also
er hat jetzt die letzten,
letzten 4-5 Jahre hat da quasi fast durchgängig
gearbeitet, kaum, kaum Urlaub gemacht.
Und hat halt quasi alles an Aufträgen
mitgenommen, was so ging. Und hat gemeint,
der würde jetzt locker über die Runden kommen.
Auch wenn jetzt der Auftrag, auch wenn jetzt
die Aufträge mal ein Jahr wegfallen.
Das wäre jetzt überhaupt kein Problem.
Der hat so viel Kohle die letzten Jahre über
gesammelt, weil er halt viele Aufträge mitgenommen hat.
Wer, er hat, er hat genug
Reserven, für ihn wäre das kein großartiges Problem
jetzt. Und da denke ich mir halt, okay,
das muss doch eigentlich für andere
Unternehmen, wo es gut läuft und
die Sache mit Hirn, mit Hirn
verwaltet wird, auch so sein,
dass man nicht nach einem Monat
am Arsch ist.
Ja, bei Lufthansa, ich kann's
bei Lufthansa irgendwo noch nachvollziehen.
Lufthansa ist gerade, gerade die ganze Tourismus-
und Reisegeschichte, die trifft's natürlich
besonders hart, aber nach einem Monat?
Ja, nach einem Monat?
Ich meine, da kann ja nicht so viel da gewesen sein.
Lufthansa hat über 130.000
mit, aber ja gut, das kostet ordentlich Kohle.
Das Problem ist, das Geld
liegt ja nicht im, oder was die EW schreibt gerade.
Das Problem ist, das Geld liegt ja nicht im
Tresor, sind ja faktisch nur virtuellige, das stimmt.
Der kleine Mann,
das ist ein Wort, das mag ich überhaupt nicht,
weil das immer mal ein Opa verwendet hat.
Das hat er immer für, ah, da kannst du jetzt
nichts für, nein, aber das hat er immer
für alle Sachen genommen, woran er Meinung
war, er wurde beschissen, hat er immer gesagt, der kleine Mann.
Kleine Firmen investieren
eher die Gewinne wieder in die Firma,
während die Großen ihre Gewinne halt irgendwo
anlegen. Wenn die nun alle anfangen,
das auszulösen, um Miete oder Löhne weiter
zu bezahlen, bricht das komplette System zusammen.
Aber so wie es aktuell ist,
müssen wir das ja dann bezahlen,
wenn wir jetzt irgendwie 10 Millionen Lufthansa retten wollen.
Weil irgendwo muss die Kohle herkommen,
wenn sie das machen wollen.
Der Selbstständige handelt kaum...
Das stimmt, wenn er daheim sitzt, hat er
nichts im Endeffekt.
Also,
ich glaube, es haben auch viele verpennt, ein bisschen.
Also, dass wir 2020
haben.
Mal sinnbildlich dafür,
dass Leute wieder in die Schule
müssen, weil wir keinen Online-Unterricht
gebacken bekommen,
wurde sicherlich in vielen
und vor allem gerade in so großen
Unternehmen viel verpennt,
was Modernisierung,
Digitalisierung und Sachen angeht.
Lufthansa will halt jetzt
viel digitalisieren.
Ja, das hätten viele vorher machen können.
Ich denke mir halt, wenn
wir es schon in der Schule
nicht gebacken bekommen und Online-Unterricht
wäre eines der einfachsten
Sachen von den
Problemen, die wir haben, die man online
hinbekommen könnte.
Online-Unterricht ist eine Sache,
das ist ja wirklich
kein Hexenwerk. Wie gesagt,
Kolumbien kriegt das gut hin.
Gut, die haben wahrscheinlich besseres Internet als wir.
Ähm...
Gerade, dass man
Online-Unterricht nicht geschissen bekommt,
finde ich irgendwie bezeichnend.
Online-Unterricht ist eine Sache,
die könnte man so gut online...
Was spricht überhaupt dagegen?
Also rein technisch gesehen
ist Online
so Education eines der
wahrscheinlich schon am
erprobtesten, was es gibt und am besten,
was man machen kann.
Aber wir kriegen das nicht gebacken.
Aber klar, die Schulen haben auch keinen Plan dafür.
Die sind nicht vorbereitet, die Lehrer haben keinen Plan.
Die wollen am liebsten ihren Overhead-Projektor
ins Internet beamen.
Das Internet bei den Leuten daheim
kackt ab.
Aber trotzdem, gerade Online-Unterricht...
Oh, das ist Chrono-Trigger-Musik.
Huge.
Beste.
Aber gerade Online-Unterricht sollte man noch hinbekommen.
Ich glaube PLA,
das war standardmäßig dabei mal.
Wie schaut es eigentlich mit VPS in Deutschland aus?
Ich glaube Strato ist ganz gut von den Preisen her.
Ich habe letztens
mal geguckt,
für Sachen, die man nur kurz braucht,
da war die Hetzner-Cloud
das Beste, was es gab.
Was trinkst du gern für Smooth-Kiwi?
Und Spinat.
Das ist
übelster Bro, den gibt es schon.
Es gibt kaum einen, der so lang...
Der heißt aber, glaube ich, auch nicht Schneider, sondern
Schneier oder so.
Muss man RTX-Voice anmachen, um die Geräusche
zu filtern?
Welche Geräusche?
Hört man irgendwelche Geräusche?
Aber das wollte ich echt mal ausprobieren.
Einfach nur um zu gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Da mache ich dann im Hintergrund ein bisschen,
um zu gucken, ob es das filtert.
Desinfektionsmittel-Spritzen.
Kekona.
Hast du gesehen, dass Xavier Naidoo Viren generell
in Frage stellt?
Ja, habe ich gesehen.
Ey, jeder was er will.
Aspedal44 von der Startseite.
Ihr habt ein Restaurant bei euch
in der Wohnsiedlung, klar.
So richtig Wohnsiedlung ist das ja auch nicht.
Hast du die Audioaufnahme von der
Online-Vorlesung im Discord gehört?
Oh ja, die war grausam.
Da war der, wie heißt das auf Deutsch,
Signalrauschabstand ziemlich
gering.
Unbedingt mal anschauen.
Was ist das jetzt?
Kann ich das gefahrlos aufmachen?
Okay, anscheinend doch nicht schlimm.
Oh ne, 3 Minuten.
Ich muss auf, ich muss pennen, Leute.
Achso, RTX, das könnte man tatsächlich ausprobieren.
Hab mir gerade mal die Hetzner Cloud angeschaut
und Ostrado ist günstiger.
Ja, wenn es rein um die Kohle geht.
Also im Bereich, wo ich letztens geguckt habe,
96 GB
und eine SSD war die Hetzner Cloud
das Beste.
Und ich brauch es ja auch nur 2-3 Stunden, dann kommt es wieder weg.
Glaubst du, dass
RTX Raytracing das nächste große Ding wird?
Oder kurz der Hype.
Das nächste große Ding wird.
Aber ich glaube, das wird uns eine Weile erhalten bleiben
und auch immer mehr genutzt werden.
Ach, da haben schon so viele Leute was drüber erzählt.
Was soll ich da noch großartig drüber erzählen?
Was sagst du zu RTX Voice?
Big Brain Technik.
Das verwirrt mich immer, dass ich Bing-Punkte kriege.
Warum kriege ich Bing-Punkte?
Ich will überhaupt gar keine Bing-Punkte haben.
Wie kriege ich das aus?
Ich will keine
Bing-Punkte.
Wie?
Wie kriege ich das weg?
Was machen die Bing-Punkte?
Keine Ahnung.
Bing-Punkte nerven, wenn man sie aufmacht.
Windows 10 1909 ist weg.
Ok.
Dann soll ich das vielleicht mal wirklich machen.
Wird es eigentlich schon gesucht?
Oh.
Feature-Update ready.
Bam.
Vielleicht lasse ich das wirklich über Nacht mal laufen.
Ist das wieder eine komplett neue
Installation?
Oder ist das wieder ein Update wie das letzte,
was keine neue Installation war,
sondern nur ein paar Dateien ausgetauscht hat?
Diese kompletten
Neuinstallations-Updates,
die sind bei mir immer ein bisschen schwierig,
weil da muss ich vorher die Festplatte entschlüsseln.
Nur Update. Excellent. Brauche ich.
Übrigens,
ich habe die Sache durchschaut.
Ist euch das mal aufgefallen eigentlich?
Ist euch
der Zusammenhang schon mal klar gewesen?
Dass heute vor 20 Jahren
Majora's Mask rauskam
und ab heute ist Maskenpflicht.
Das ist mal wirklich
eher NWO.
Da sieht man es wieder.
Max hat da eine heiße Spur.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Gut, also.
Ja, das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Scheiße, bin ich alt, als ich 20 Jahre gesehen habe.
Ist mir auch genau das gleiche
habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Okay, Leute.
Ich muss jetzt off.
Morgen früh.
Zum Glück wieder Homeoffice.
Bisschen länger pennen.
Vielleicht bin ich morgen Abend schon wieder am Start.
Ach, der Eax ist ja da. Moin.
Spielst du noch Valorant?
Wir hatten es ja kurz
im Discord drüber.
Ich habe mittlerweile auch
einen Account.
Aber ich habe es noch nicht gespielt.
So, gibt es denn jemanden,
den wir hosten können?
Der es braucht.
Ähm.
Nicht wirklich.
Wir könnten den Cyrus wieder hosten.
Ach ne, der ist gerade aufgegangen.
Mach mal Twitch Partnerschaft.
Klar für mich.
Ich glaube, da habe ich wenig Einfluss drauf.
Aber du könntest mal ein bisschen Valorant streamen.
Aber Valorant Anti-Cheat.
Rootkid.
Poggers.
Oder vieles Batman, je nachdem.
Du zockst noch Fünfergruppen.
Wie? Hast du keinen Bock auf random, toxic
Matchmaking?
Ja.
Ich glaube, du hast es.
Da hatte ich Overwatch verdorben.
Ich ertrage das jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Wenn ich schon irgendwelche Spasten im
Voice-Chat höre, kriege ich schon Anfälle.
Das triggert mich sogar in Streams
nach Overwatch jetzt.
Es reicht schon, wenn ich Livestreams
gucke und ich irgendwelche Deppen
im Voice-Chat höre.
Da weiß ich schon, dass ich keinen Bock drauf habe.
Das kannst du in EU knicken.
Ja, das stimmt.
Du hast gesagt, dass man französisch redet
und die anderen versuchen, Englisch zu reden.
Aber der Franzose macht nicht mit, Englisch zu reden.
Franzosen sind ja gerade, was Online angeht,
Online-Kommunikation angeht,
nicht gerade Vorbilder.
Oui, oui.
Okay, was auch immer, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt auf. Bis morgen. Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut. See you.